hello my name is Sophie I'm a PhD
student at the Karolinska Institute and
today I'm meeting Francis Arnold to ask
her some questions
congratulations I must say actually
first of all thank you I wanted to
actually start with just asking you in
terms of motivation like where do you
think you get the most motivation from
to do your research it just comes I love
what I do I enjoy it every day I'd go in
excited about seeing the people that I
work with the problems that we're
working on yeah I would do it for free
but do you think it has changed from
when you were a PhD to like a postdoc
and then being a PI and having your own
lab of where you get that kind of joy
from or is it the same kind of inner
source somehow that magically is just
there
well the joy comes up and down right
there some days are less joyful than
others but it's it gets easier as you go
through your career it does well because
think about it I have 20 people in my
group so I can focus on the good things
that are happening and the poor people
that are struggling their days are not
very joyful but mine are joyful because
I get to focus on all the other good
things so I get to spread it out a
little bit more now that I'm leading a
group but even as a graduate student you
have the joy of learning of filling your
brain with completely new ideas of
listening to the best people in the
world I was at Berkeley at the time my
teachers were household names in
biochemistry and engineering so for me
that joy was just taking in all this new
knowledge so how come that you went into
chemistry and when do you think that was
I mean okay today of course it was the
right move now you know right there were
you scared about it where it's not the
least bit I was not the least bit scared
and I'll tell you that the people who
joined my laboratory no one knows
anything about protein engineering I
chemists who've been synthetic organic
chemists doing chemistry with the top
groups never touched a protein in their
lives never grew a bacterium other than
inside their refrigerator I take those
people and they learn something totally
new and those are the adventuresome ones
those are the people who will change the
world
right because they're willing to step
out often from a whole new country doing
whole new science and if you can't do
that when you're 22 when can you do it
is that what you look for in people when
they come turning your lap fearlessness
fearlessness fearlessness you've got a
if you're going to change the world
you've got to try really different
things fair enough yeah I wanted to ask
you also because they're the Nobel Prize
it's awarded to whomever this year of
course then did the most for humankind
and what aspect you think in your
science did the most for humankind I
mean if it's a it's a great discovery
but of course also it has from what I've
understood I'm not a chemist right but
you can use it actually to a lot of
different approaches or a lot of
different things look at chemistry
chemistry makes everything we use in our
daily lives everything in this room was
made by chemistry and in the past
chemistry hasn't been very clean we
create a lot of waste in the industry we
use toxic metals that have to be mined
and create pollution
I want to revolutionize the way we make
chemistry and the way we do chemistry
I'd love to see all chemists replaced by
bacteria my chemistry friends aren't too
happy about that but think about making
all the molecules and chemicals and
fuels and food we need from renewable
resources in a clean biological process
that's a great vision somebody has to
implement it and those are the methods
that I've developed to do that so
they're used by lots of different people
in companies and
different research labs and we're
starting to learn how to program
chemistry in DNA but you're not scared
if you imagine that scenario then this
bacteria would be everywhere it's also a
bit ok cloning is not my strong suit
also in terms of you know bacteria up
and using but it's a lot of antibiotic
resistant genes that are used also in in
growing bacteria it's not something that
scares you in this utopia where
everything is done by bacteria
well I use bacteria you could use plants
you could use yeast the bacteria are not
the problem these are really harmless
organisms and they're all contained in
vessels but this is chemistry that gets
done in water for the price of sugar and
sunlight what's better than that but
does this cell so in terms of where you
think science should go and I'm not
talking necessarily about chemistry but
in a very broad sense imagine if you got
to choose now pointing the finger to
what we're going this direction the
scientific community lets you know let's
go this way where do you think we should
go well we clearly have to figure out
how to live sustainably right if we're
going to feed house clothe and give
water to 10 billion people and we still
want to plan it that has some natural
world in it we have to figure out how to
do that much much more efficiently than
we're doing now is not always the
motivation for you always yeah you had
that elected in the very first I worked
in the solar energy field when I was
just right out of university my first
job was doing solar collectors in Brazil
and then at the Solar Energy Research
Institute when Carter was our president
we actually had a national goal of 20%
renewable energy by the year 2000 that's
what I wanted to do I wanted to create
or help create the technologies that
would help us transition from
non-renewable resources like pumping oil
out of the ground to living in a
sustainable world that's really amazing
that you're also new I mean that you had
that goal and then you really
it's uh it's very impressive if you
hadn't a different beginning of what you
wanted to achieve in this perfect world
but I also wanted to ask you when you
started and from what the scientific
community is now what do you think has
changed and what are the pros and the
cons of what science was maybe when you
started and what it is today
because it's changing quite rapidly of
how we do it things it's moving ever
faster science the world is changing
very quickly science moves very quickly
the the rate of information I feel like
I've got a computer in my head now doing
email all the time so it we have less
time to think and to ponder
I have to make time to read and to think
if I want if I value that and that seems
to me the biggest change maybe that's
just a change in my life though do you
feel that you have time to think no it's
actually for the first time because you
know you do your PhD and there's a lot
of experiments to be done and love data
type be analyzed and all of these things
I'm and now I'm writing a review article
and that's actually the first time that
I really feel that I get to go to work
and read what other people are doing and
then think about it and see you know
what do I really think about how these
people are doing science where is my
field actually because I started off
with a certain amount of knowledge and
then you know you work you work so much
that at some point you kind of forget to
to go back again and check wait where is
my field now you know there's well
that's a good point that's a good
mechanism so I ask students to prepare
reviews like that in order to force them
to read the literature but it's still
the literature in a well-defined field
where do you have time to read a book on
philosophy or to think about something
else and then see the connections how
that really that you you just went and
studied this aspect of biochemistry for
the fun of it but then you see the
connections how it plays into your field
we need the chance to do that but it
seems to get more and more difficult
yeah it's a lot there's a lot of
information that's kind of always
drowning you but it's a it's a luxury
problem in its and so also but it's it's
true that you and especially this
feeling of that one thing to stumble on
another kind of discovery and then
realizing that wait I can you know I can
use this and what I do but this kind of
time where you get to read things just
for fun and the other big change is a
ever stronger emphasis on solving a
problem now and that's distressing to me
because I'm a problem solver I'm an
engineer I love doing practical research
but I never take on a problem that's
going to be a practical solution in two
years company should do that that should
be done in industry where the problem is
well-defined
where there's a solution that can be
developed that you have that a good idea
where in in academic research to play is
generating these new ideas new
technologies thinking broadly that gives
you some new way of thinking about a
problem and it could be 10 20 years off
but if you don't invest in that now 20
years from now you're not you're just
going to have obvious trivial solutions
I think it's a it's very true do you
have somebody in mind that you think has
this attitude somebody that you're
looking up to and saying that you know
this is actually how one should do it
can you give an example of something
that you think does this the Nobel Prize
in Physics last year my colleagues at
Caltech worked on this problem for 21
years and there was never a guarantee
that it would be successful that's just
an amazing story what they did with the
LIGO project you have to really believe
in something and work hard without much
credit for a long time thank you so much
for taking this time to sit with us
today thank you
I just finished meeting Francis Arnold
it was really lovely to meet her and
hearing her advice on how one should be
fearless in science but also have the
patience to pursue long-term goals